I've been telling you for months now
that no matter what the polls say about
Ted Cruz versus Beto O'Rourke in Texas
no matter who's raising more money no
matter how deceptive and desperate Ted
Cruz's fundraising appeals are this is
an uphill battle and this is an uphill
battle for better or ork because
incumbency is powerful it's an uphill
battle because Texas is a place where
Republicans vote much more than
Democrats do and this is also because
there are more people out there who
might show up and just vote a straight
Republican ticket without having paid
attention to the details of Beto
O'Rourke versus Ted Cruz so we knew that
it was going to be difficult but we now
have acutely bad news there's a new
Quinnipiac poll which looked at likely
voters instead of registered voters and
it has Ted Cruz up nine fifty four to
forty five the argument for doing a poll
of likely voters instead of registered
voters is that listen there's a lot of
registered voters who aren't going to
vote on November 6 who haven't voted for
a long time so in order to see who's
winning we should look at who is likely
to vote when Quinnipiac surveyed
registered voters the lead for Cruz had
been as small as three but now they're
likely voter model has Ted Cruz up nine
so the importance thing thing thing to
think about here is if they're tied in
one poll among registered voters but
Cruz's up among likely voters like let's
assume the polls are correct you can
deal with that by just getting people to
vote right like turnout in these
midterms is anywhere from twenty-five to
forty five percent if the registered
voters like Beto or work just get them
to the polls and you can swing the
election on turnout that's that's one
thing the other thing to think about is
that likely voter models understate the
young vote because a common question in
figuring out if someone is likely to
vote is have you voted before if you're
too young to have voted before the model
may not consider you a likely voter but
this might be your first time voting and
you might be damn sure that you're
getting out there and voting for better
or work but it's time for the left to
get very active here right whether it's
phone banking
donating or volunteering this is not
going to be an easy one and now is the
time to do it and really this might even
be a better headline for better or work
to get his supporters to vote right if
you see a headline that says I don't
know Beto up to maybe you stay home this
is a call to action and I hope people
will see it and not be discouraged by
Beto being down 9 in this poll yeah
there's an argument to be made that
Hillary Clinton lost because all the
polls had her up ahead of the election
so people who didn't really like Hillary
Clinton but certainly preferred her over
Trump just decided to stay home because
she was a shoo-in and that didn't turn
out so well yeah and it didn't make a
difference in California but ultimately
in the 77 thousand votes that across
three states ended up handing Donald
Trump the victory you could say it did
make a difference only 20-something I
think in Wisconsin really
I mean 77,000 across three states that's
that's only about 25,000 per state but
that's why you need to think about every
race is 50/50 and think about it as
coming down to turnout and in reality
when turnout in the midterms is
pathetically low it is as it is in the
United States I think sometimes midterm
turnout is like in the 20s I don't know
why I have 28 percent as like a midterm
turnout number from some prior midterms
but certainly not going higher than like
45 percent it's not wrong to think that
you can win on turnout alone and
hopefully better Aurora can do it but I
told you that it was going to go in the
direction of Cruz as we got closer to
November 6 I don't think this is any
normal midterm though because Donald
Trump is so polarizing he's so unpopular
when it comes to the left and I think
that will cause progressives to turn out
and vote in Texas
even if historically there's a voter
turnout edge for Republicans in Texas
maybe that won't it won't happen this
time because everything really is new
and I hope that on November 7th and we
come in all of this stuff has come to
fruition and we have some good numbers
to report to you one of today's sponsors
is Skillshare which is an incredible
online learning community offering over
10,000 high-quality online courses on a
huge variety of topics the first 500
people who click the link under this
video will get two entire months
totally free access to every single
class offered by Skillshare you'll have
free access to courses on music art
photography business computer
programming cooking meditation and
everything in between I think you'll
have no problem finding courses that are
perfect for you I just took a really
fascinating class on watercolour
painting which I am not yet at the level
of trying to perfect but more the level
of trying to learn even just a little
bit about our show is giving you two
entire months of totally free access to
every course offered by Skillshare risk
free if you click the link under this
video you'll have two whole months to
take classes on anything you're
passionate about classes taught by real
people who share your passion and after
that you can keep getting access to the
entire site for less than ten bucks a
month
just click the link under this video to
redeem your to three months of
Skillshare but hurry because it's only
available to the first 500 people who
sign up